- As someone that has to
work out as for a job,
I promise you I would not look like this
unless I had to be naked in
most of my movies, mostly.
And like at some point I
gotta get better at acting
so I don't have to be
naked and all of them.
(laughing)
- Oh my god.
- But she is just incredible.
I really, I mean, I literally
get to work out as a job
and it is, it's still hard.
And I can't imagine people
that have a nine to five job,
have kids at home and then
where do they get the energy
and the time to to
actually like, you know,
focus on themselves.
And I just think it's really
beautiful what she's doing.
- Absolutely and you get it, you're a dad.
It's like there's a lot of
time, like just for work.
And then you're a dad.
It's like, it's a lot.
Like to fit everything in.
So do you, do you do
like massive cheat days?
'Cause Dwayne Johnson was on here
and he showed me his
cheat day and I was like,
first of all I would barf if I ate
all the things he ate on his cheat day.
But do you have massive ones?
- I sometimes do, not like
not like massive ones.
'Cause I think as I'm getting older,
it's really getting, like
everything I pick up,
I just go, oh that's like two more miles
that I have to run or ride.
(Kelly laughing)
And it's like, I just started looking
at things like they're just actual miles
and time that I have to work out.
So I will pick the days
and I will pick very specific things.
I love cake but, but yeah.
- Oh my god, me too.
(Channing laughing)